of that breaking news this afternoon
that harry maguire the manchester united
captain and the england footballer today
selected to play for
england's upcoming teams has been found
guilty along with his co-defendants
christopher sharman and joe mcguire
of all charges those charges were of
aggravated assault
and attempted bribery of an official
it's been an astonishing day
in court in the neighboring island of
cirrus a few
hundred miles away from mykonos where
the incidents
took place on saturday night things
moving incredibly quickly with
harry maguire's defense team asking the
judge
if they could have more time to prepare
for this case
the judge making it very clear that he
wanted to proceed
as quickly as possible and this evening
uh those verdicts have come in and we
are being told that we can expect
sentencing as well this evening so we
will be keeping a close eye on those
developments
in cyros but that breaking news this
evening that
harry maguire has been found guilty of
aggravated assault and attempted bribery
in mykonos at the weekend